Samuel thank you so much for joining me
this morning thanks for having me on the
show it's great to be here I listen to
you guys all the time and really love
this channel did you grow up in church
yeah kind of I did really yeah I mean I
didn't grow up not knowing who God was
and about the Christian faith but it was
I was 17 when I thought for the first
time had my own seriously kind of
spiritual experience where I met Jesus
for myself but yeah I grew up knowing
about Jesus for sure when you say met
Jesus for yourself I mean what was that
I mean it went from it went from theory
it went from knowledge in my head to
something active in my heart I went from
knowing about Jesus oh yeah I've heard
some stories I know that to actually
experiencing him as a person and Meggitt
life-changing over 10 years ago but
completely changed my life and it's
that's the the core of me is my faith
now and is my love for God on people
yeah how did it change your life it
changed my life because what on a
practical level
I don't before I met Jesus I had a lot
of people that I didn't like either a
little list of people that I wanted to
get revenge on Wow it was a deep-rooted
serious serious list you know like I
just feel like it into until I met Jesus
before that I was wanting to live life
on my chest my ideal situation would be
I live my life how I want but then just
before I die on my deathbed then I
repent and go to heaven
right and then I think when I met Jesus
thought wow this actually heaven can
start right now but I have to wait until
I die if I'm if I'm gonna wait some I'm
dead then death is my Savior but
actually Jesus is my Savior and eternal
life starts right now and I let go of
all that all that anger or all those
enemies I let go of that and just let
Jesus reign and I'm far from a perfect
human being I'm far from a saint all
right a million percent but at the same
time I know I know that Jesus forgives
me and I know that God's my papa
so life's just brilliant so you
how did you get into property investing
well I wanted to go to church on Sunday
but I couldn't because I worked for my
dad and my dad had an entertainment
agency where he was doing you know
children's parties and magic shows so my
whole life was revolved around that and
it was empty and he didn't give me
fulfilment I didn't want to do that as a
job
it meant I couldn't go to church on a
Sunday because I had to be working and I
just thought I can't be doing with this
however I can't quit cuz that'll be
irresponsible I need I need to do
something else and I went to a I read a
read a book about property and business
and I went to a property conference and
thought hey I could do that I could make
a living as a property entrepreneur
there's people doing it those people I
met I saw people doing it so I quit my
job for my dad said to pursue this
property entrepreneur career and I was
living at home so I didn't have to make
a living so I didn't have anything to
lose and that's how it started for me
you mentioned that your crash course
that you started to do well and there
seem to be some changes that your church
that you were at the time had towards
you which were not positive yeah what
happened so I think the thing is there's
an idea in the church and with a lot of
people in general certainly within
Christianity that there's a direct
correlation between how much money you
make and how spiritual you are and
depending on what church you go to some
churches might be heavy heavy on
Prosperity which is which is cool but
what's not cool is when they say if you
make a lot of money therefore that's God
blessing you because the the contrary is
therefore if you're not making a lot of
money it's because you're in sin yeah
and what they're saying is there's a
correlation between your bank balance
and your spirituality now my church it
was the same with the other way around
which was people would wear poverty like
a badge of honor ex brethren roots and
if you make a lot of money that means
that you're greedy because if you make
more than you need why would the idea is
what would you do that
so when I started out in properties an
entrepreneur I told my church I told my
pastor I'm doing this because I want to
be able to come to church on Sundays I
want to be able to fund my I want to be
able to fund my ministry I want to go
out and tell people about Jesus in the
streets of my town and set up a Youth
Center and I want to be active in the
church you want to go out to put the
Blanco in Spain and working a drug rehab
center I want to get to Zambia and help
people you know I want it so I need some
form of income
yeah exactly and I don't want to be a
full-time fundraiser I want to be able
to be self-sufficient and they were cool
with that cool temp makin pay your way
and then go help people when I started
to surrender my first property deal it
was like a good job when the problem
came was when I became more successful
than the average person so when I had
like ten twelve houses and I'm 20 it's
like it's like you know you earn enough
houses now that was the that was the
mentality and I began to feel guilty you
know I began to feel guilty because um
there be a lot of focus in my church
around versus like a rich man getting
into heaven is like a camel getting
through the either needle and then and
then there's a full stop but in reality
there's actually a comma and he goes on
to say but what is impossible with man
is possible with God
so a lot of these verses in the Bible
that talk about money
III I feel now like they're taken out of
context and also not in taken out of
context but Miss quoted like money's the
root of all evil another the Bible
actually says it's the love of money
which is an addiction never ending never
so I feel like people my teachers my
spiritual teachers have a very incorrect
view around money as a result of that me
being a business person whose incentive
was to go make money there was a royal
conflict and that's why I ended up going
study and epigenomics so that must have
been quite a painful experience yeah and
a lot of times you know we grow up in
church and you get hurt maybe by your
leaders or to someone who's injured
and that resentment builds up you want
nothing to do nothing to do with God how
did you not leave what kept you jeez
that's a great question because you know
I almost did I almost did because I
think that's one of the things that
doesn't help and this is not just about
this topic in general but is easy to
think because someone is a pastor or a
spiritual leader or a Christian leader
or whatever therefore they're super
human and you put you put them you put
people on a pedestal and then when they
slip up or make a mistake or judge you
or do anything wrong against you there's
some me it's like oh my gosh they're an
awful person they're a fraud no no no
they're just a human being and everybody
is everybody makes mistakes
so yes sure my church messed up it took
to a point and I ended up almost getting
pushed out the church which was really
painful but at the end of the day I
think it was coming from a position of
ignorance on their part rather than
malice yeah and I think that people even
even in my family misunderstood me
now I'm wildly successful I make a lot
of money and going from a working-class
Christian to becoming a wildly
successful businessman it did it it did
upset some feathers it did put not noses
out of joint people but I think more
than anything it was people not jealous
but misunderstanding me and trying to
protect me trying to guard me like oh my
gosh you know but but i but I I I think
some people are called to be business
men and women I should hope so
for sure yeah God is a practical God he
wants you to he God invented mass and
matter and science and just get on with
it and be practical and I just think
sometimes is easy to just mess around
and pray about everything and yes your
life should be a prayerful life when
you're they're constantly constantly
connected we've got listening to his
voice but I know I've been guilty of
just over sometimes you can be too so
spiritually it can be an excuse for a
lack of activity people say do you want
or do you want to come and do X Y Z in
you know that really it'll be a great
thing to do but you'd rather what you
stand
so you just say I'll pray about that
brother that is what I mean by drop the
spiritual baggage yeah
and had what makes you so focused so
determined you know when when people die
they'll have a tombstone and on the
tombstone there were two dates of a - in
the middle I'm very aware that I'm in
the - the Bible says that we're here
today gone tomorrow the grass with it
you know is just life is short man I
know I'm just I'm just past the point of
wasting time caring what people think I
just I don't know why I'm wide that way
because because I think it's partly
because of my faith and my belief in God
but it's partly just a worm wired
[Music]